If they've got their own guys
that's, that's great. Jackson,
they've got their own people.
Um,
but you know w w there's plenty of people
on the roster that have an MMA coach
and a grappling coach and that's it.
So the performance institute, we,
we feel we can help and support those guys
as well. You can bridge the gap. Right.
And we're not trying to displace the
programs where athletes already have
resources,
but I don't know of another MMA gym
globally that has the capacity around
assessment that we do. So yeah, we have,
we have some really great practitioners
but Bose and of our strength coach and
his team can not write programs for
570 athletes. Yup. It's not possible.
But what we can do is
assess those athletes,
provide that feedback back to their
strength coaches and have conversations
about how those coaches
can use that data to,
to support the development of that athlete
and that that goes across the board
for all of our performance services.
What's pretty amazing resource because
if you're a young fighter and all you
have is access to the people around you,
you get, if you're fighting in the UFC,
you get to have access like
instantaneously to this
gigantic group of people
where it's like when forest,
when you were coming up,
you mean you are a real pioneer. I mean
that was, that was not available to a guy.
Like, you know, I mean
I tell the story all the time,
but so I was actually a little bit
ahead of my time. I had, you know,
I had an actual strength coach that
had letters behind his name and went to
college to be a strength coach. Not there
was like an ex bodybuilder. Uh, I had a,
you know,
a relatively good nutritionist who at
least had a degree in chemical biology.
Uh,
I had a good physical therapist,
but I didn't really have like
I was my coach, you know,
at the end of the day I was the head
of performance. So I'd go do Jujitsu.
Jujitsu coach wants you to go hard and
then you go kickbox but you're going to
go light. But it's kicked
by it so you don't, and then
you know, and now you know,
nobody's the strength coach and
nutritionist on different pages.
So I think just understanding that
everything has to work together,
which I didn't really understand.
Well,
the one I'm saying is that you kind of
had to pave a path because when a guy
like you was doing all that stuff with
a real legitimate strength condition
coach,
real legitimate nutritionist,
how many other people were doing that at
your time? Not that many, but I, yeah,
be around good people like Randy couture,
chocolate down.
Those were kind of guys I got to hang
out with and say, well, he does this.
He does a chuck actually what
ended that much of this stuff.
But Randy was, Chuck's was right. I know
what I'm doing. K. All right. Yes sir.
Yeah, he'd just existed
on pure savagery. Um,
when you step back and look
at your career, like how,
how amazing is it to be able to step off
from there and do something like you're
doing now for the UFC
performance institute was just
very meaningful for young
fighters.
When you really do get a chance to
give back with your experience and your
understanding of the right way and the
wrong way, the mistakes that you've made.
I mean, it's huge. I
mean, that's the whole,
I mean that's the whole genesis kind of
from, from my involvement in the pie.
Like, oh look, here's the
10,000 mistakes I made. Yeah,
you're gonna make mistakes too. But he,
these are the ones you don't need to make.
You know, again, the sport's changed, man.
It's 25 years old. Every other sports,
so all been around so long.
Our sport changes all the time.
I forget who was talking about it,
but you know,
even the guys fighting 10 years ago
probably couldn't compete with guests
fighting today,
you know?
But I mean what I would say as well
and is not only for the fighters,
Forrest is a huge results for us.
The bet,
the best piece of technology we have
is that they'll handle it leads from my
office to up to four Esophagus,
right?
Because ultimately he's a massive results
for us that are not necessarily coming
from an NMA background and are trying
to support the MMA community to,
to bounce ideas off to essentially
Beta test things from a thought process
perspective.
And he's a huge part of the performance
institute philosophy because we can use
and call upon his ex.
Here's another funny thing. When we
were putting together the, the uh,
the team for the Pii,
I kind of shied away from,
people already do an MMA.
I wanted combat sports.
Everybody that's done it has done
judo boxing on an Olympic level.
They've done combat sports.
But I wanted like a fresh set of eyes
coming from a different, you know,
than just ah, you know, cause I know
really good MMA strength coaches.
I know pretty good. Emma, you
know, you, you know, good. But get,
get that fresh set of eyes.
You know,
nutrition actually was a little different
because the rest of the world does not
understand awake cut for an MMA fight.
It's not like a, you know, we go to Exos,
you go to any high level
facility and they, you say,
I'm going to lose 8% of my body weight,
and then competed on Saturday.
They're like, no, don't just fight
in highway class. I'm like, yeah,
that actually isn't gonna work out for me.
They,
they just won't comprehend it
though. No, no. You'll perform
better. Like, no, no, no.